(logo whooshing)
(gentle music)
(upbeat music)
- America, (laughs) what a place.
- My father gave his life making this country what it is.
(upbeat music)
(tinkly piano music)
(girl lightly snoring)
(alarm clock ringing)
(upbeat music)
- I'd like to talk about this $7 blender,
I'll give you four.
- This I my money that I earned.
It's not Marvin's money, it's my money.
(upbeat music)
(baby groaning)
- It's a sweater!
(upbeat music)
- What is it?
- It's a bundt.
- Bunk, bunk.
- Bundt.
- It's a cake!
- Play nice with the other kids unless of course,
one of the other kids want to fight,
then you have to kick the other kid's butt.
- But I don't want to kick the other kid's butt.
(upbeat music)
- [All] Immigrants, we get the job done.
(logo whooshing)
(logo squeaking)